حسنًا للقول إن المسؤولين الأوكرانيين كانوا
مستائين من أن تصريحات الرئيس بايدن ستكون بخسًا ، أخبرني
أحد
المسؤولين أنه صُدم عندما
سمع الزعيم الأمريكي يميز بين
التوغل والغزو ويقترح
أن توغلًا طفيفًا من قبل روسيا
وأراضي أوكرانيا سيكون أقل من ذلك.
استجابة من غزو واسع النطاق الآن ،
حيث ربما تمت مناقشة النطاق المتدرج للعقوبات
على انفراد ، لكن
المسؤولين الأوكرانيين يقولون إن هذه هي
المرة الأولى التي سمعوا فيها أن الفوارق الدقيقة
تجعلنا عادةً مسؤولين مثل
وزير الخارجية الأمريكي أنتوني بلينكين الذي
كان موجودًا بالفعل هنا في كييف.  عندما
تحدث الرئيس بايدن
عن عقوبات ساحقة أو
عواقب وخيمة إذا كان هناك أي نوع من
العمل العسكري ضد أوكرانيا ، فإن
القلق الرئيسي وفقًا للمسؤولين الأوكرانيين
الذين تحدثت معهم هو أن الملاحظات الجديدة
قد يُنظر إليها على أنها روسيا باعتبارها اقتباسًا من
الضوء الأخضر لدخول بوتين.
وبعبارة أخرى ، تسعد أوكرانيا بالاستيلاء على
الأراضي بشكل محدود كما حدث في
ر  لقد تجاوز عقوباتنا الخفيفة فقط
ردًا على ذلك جيدًا ،
سارع البيت الأبيض إلى إصدار توضيح
لملاحظات الرئيس بايدن قائلاً إن
التوغل البسيط
قد يشمل شيئًا مثل هجوم إلكتروني ،
ولكن إن وجد ، إذا كان هناك أي
مصادرة أخرى للأراضي الأوكرانية يمكن
رؤيتها
كغزو ويقابله رد سريع وشديد وموحد ماثيو
فرصة cnn kiev